foreign
[Music]
do you think when I found the evidence
he looked at me smiled and said you've
had nine years to be the woman I love
[Music]
you good morning good afternoon good
night this is the Dr John deloney show
and I'm so grateful that you have joined
us
a show about you
to show with you to show for you real
people call them with real challenges
and
I'll sit down and I'll walk alongside
you and we will figure this thing out I
won't sit down and walk I'll either sit
down with you or walk alongside you
whichever is more comfortable for you
we're gonna figure out what is the next
thing that you gotta do and we're
talking mental health we're talking
relationships we're talking family
trauma we're talking kids we're talking
whatever else is going on in your life
been doing this for 20 something years
sitting with people when the wheels have
fallen off and my promise is I'm gonna
tell you the truth and we're gonna
figure out what to do next if you want
to be on the show give me a call at John
yeah go to the Internet John deloney.com
ask or give me a call on the telephone
the way God intended us to talk to one
another
um
1-844-693-3291 is that right no you're
shaking your head at me no no that's
just in general
yes the phone number was right that was
just in general yeah
just if you were to sit in my seat
during the day recording this show this
Kelly spends 85 percent of it just
shaking your head and it's mostly
existential like what did I do in some
former life that this is my penance
that this is
this is my career this is my job this
guy
man talk about winning the lottery you
got like the two dollar scratch off
where you kind of won something but it's
like not a lot it's enough to buy two
more tickets really yeah because I mean
you know I was working on the second
largest
talk show in America yes and then
near near
okay quick uh quick aside America if
you're trying to hit the 15 second skip
button you can go to the call but
so my wife had this student um this is
years and years ago that all the
teachers were cleaning up this huge
craft project and
um
he came after that they just you know
they lay out these big long tables of
paper and it's in this cafeteria and
they're cleaning up the paper and all
the stuff they just wad it all up and
throw it in the trash out in the trash
don't in the trash
and this sweet kid comes and says hey my
glasses were in there
so these teachers go through the
dumpster diving for this young child's
glasses it's a whole thing and then out
of nowhere the kid comes running out of
the classroom it's like I had my glasses
they were in my bag and he goes near
and here I am 20 years later and when
something great happens in my life I go
near
still
because I'm seven all right let's go to
Los Angeles California and talk to Anna
you're near what's up Anna
Hi how are you I I don't know I don't
know
I'm not very good at my job today how
are you
uh same I don't
answer that all right I will help I'll
help you if you'll help me how about
that yeah
yeah all right so what's up
um so my question is
um
that is it was um if my favorite do me a
favor take a huge huge deep breath as
deep as you can and hold it
one two three let it out
and then do do that one more time as
deep as you can all the way from the
inside of your guts
one two three drop it okay
all right I'm with you
okay
um if my husband's cheating yeah no no
I knew what you're gonna ask as you were
asking the question no
why in the world would you think that
and her and the messages and everything
and I told him oh
check your hidden album
he looked at me smiled
like the most evil smile I've ever seen
them do and said you've had nine years
to be the woman I love
I'm sorry I'm so sorry
I want you to consider a guy that would
so
um
disgusting is the word uh cheat on his
wife
is a person of so low character that the
words they say
aren't to be trusted either
so don't not trust him and don't not
trust his actions but then take a piece
of the ugliest most hurtful thing he
said and trust that as truth because
it's a lie too
oh
so what's your next move
um I don't know because he's been
cheating on me since I was nine months
pregnant and we have a eight month old
now
you still staying in the home
he actually shipped this
this we we're living in Collin County
Texas
and he shipped this off to California
because this is where my mom is this is
where my family is and his family too
and he put us on a plane three months
ago
um and now he's saying he wants to work
things out and fight for his family and
fight you know be in my baby's life but
it wasn't just
it wasn't just me he was he's a first
responder so his his work schedule is 24
hour shifts
and he was pretending to work a lot of
overtime and making trades and going and
spending
you know days with this other woman
from our gym and um
I told them it wasn't I've been there
when when my dad said oh I'm not leaving
your mom or I'm not leaving you girls
I'm leaving your mom too I said I know
how this works
you're not you say you're leaving me but
you're also you're not leaving the baby
you're just leaving me but you don't
call you don't FaceTime him you don't
initiate things to see him and he says
well because I I have to deal with you
and I don't want to deal with you so
I'd rather not if it means I don't have
to see him then
you understand that that doesn't make
sense on its face
yeah and that's exactly what I I said I
was like you don't make sense because if
you want to see him it doesn't matter
stop let's do this let's do this
you are in the
smoke and fog and Ash of a fire that
just burned right through your house
and you're trying to forensically figure
out why in the world this fire burned
and what it burned
you got to get out of the burned spot
okay
um as far as I'm concerned right now
your marriage is over
yeah behavior is a language he has told
you loud and clear
he does not want to be a father
he does not want to be a husband
he doesn't want to be a person of
character or integrity
because here's what I know
if let's say
I God forbid I had a long-term affair
behind my wife's back
and she caught me
and I took that Affair and I stabbed her
with it like he did with you
and then
I was such a spineless coward
that I put my wife and newborn on a
plane and sent them away out of our home
let's say I did all that and then I woke
up one day
and I realized I couldn't breathe and I
realized I had made the craziest most
insane mistake of my life
I don't pick up a phone or a text
message and say I really want to fight
for this
I find the nearest First I find the
first flight out and if there's not a
first flight I drive
and I bang the door down and say I've
made the most catastrophic mistake of my
life I quit my job I quit everything
because you are everything
that's what you do
and so
I'm gonna tell you something crazy I'm
not hating on him for having an affair
those are wrong and they happen
foreign
but he's been a he's displayed a gross
lack of character
and he's trying to drag his youth
through his guilt right
yes
so what you've got to stop doing is
trying to make rational a an insane
irrational Act
you are allowed to be pregnant Anna if
that's answering your question
were you always uh roses and
a joy to be around probably not no no
did he come to you and say hey I feel
like I'm losing my wife I want to
reconnect let's no he didn't do that he
went to the gym
yeah okay
and to be fair you didn't either
but no he made a choice
he looked you in the eye and he said for
you forever and then one day he went to
the gym and was like eh and her
mid-choice
okay
so from this second forward you can no
longer carry the cinder block that is
his choices that's not your fault
mm-hmm
the question you've got to ask yourself
is what is Anna gonna do next because
right now he doesn't get a vote he
kicked you all out cool I'm gonna go
make my life
yeah that's that's what I said I said I
don't feel comfortable going back to
Texas absolutely not
he kicked you out you and your newborn
who kicks out a newborn
there's been moments when my wife wanted
to kick me out and that's fair not kick
me out forever but like you should
probably leave right and I'm a lot I get
that and there's been times I'm like I
don't want to be around her that's fair
who kicked out a newborn
yeah it was um
it was supposed to be only a two-month
like he said oh let's give it two months
and then we can reconnect as like uh
the heart like distance makes the heart
grow fonder
yeah that works so good
um yeah I found this calendar synced up
literally the day before with this other
woman from the gym and he said no it's
strictly platonic
you're looping on it
you
are like somebody who lost somebody that
you love deeply in an act in a car
accident and you keep going back and
looking at the accident photos you have
to stop doing that
you're not gonna find peace in what he
did
and your sweet body's been through this
before when your dad took off on your
family right
[Music]
so this has double weight because this
wasn't going to be what happened to you
I'm so so so sorry
I want you to
you're not asking so I'm just putting
this out there okay and you can just
blow it off and that won't bother me a
bit
but I think it's time for you to sit
down with
a counselor and say
dad left me and I still don't understand
why what I did
and
my first responder supposed to be a hero
husband
made a beautiful baby with me and he
left me and now that same seven-year-old
is inside of me asking me what's wrong
with me again
and you're gonna have to heal from that
question
because it's going to affect everything
you do for the rest of your life
and the truth is
the answer is nothing on both counts
you didn't make your husband cheat and
you didn't make your dad leave
will you hold that sweet little baby
close to your chest and promise that
baby that you will go get healthy is it
a girl or boy
a boy I want you to commit to yourself
and that little boy
that this generational hurt stops with
you
and you're going to go do the work that
you need to do
to make peace with the demons that are
still calling you from when you were a
little kid
and you're going to get some peace and
some your footing underneath you so you
can make the hard decisions that you got
coming ahead
yes sir is that fair
yeah
do you have some a bill you have some
resources to go see a counselor there in
your community
um I think
um
I've talked to a few but it's just
they're just people I haven't really
connected with so I'm still looking all
right I want you just I want you to stay
on the line I'm gonna hook you up with
several months of better help for free
okay okay and that's a good place for
you to start
are your parents trustworthy or is his
parents trustworthy do you have friends
there in California
oh my my entire Community is out here at
my church everyone
so I want you to go sit with one or two
women that you trust
that you love and that you care about
and you can be honest with and I want
you to sit down and tell them everything
but I don't want you to rehash all the
the what happens the everything I'm
talking about is I want you to tell them
how devastating this was
once you tell them how much it hurts and
how confusing figuring out your next
right step is because I can hear your
you have a very
trauma based response going on right now
which of course makes sense but you're
going back trying to figure out what
happened so that you can
justify going back with this guy if you
end up back with him you end up back
with him I'm not going to hate on you
for that
but there's got to be some healing that
happens or this whole thing this whole
Loop starts over again and starts over
again
and again as I said when this call
started
he's a person who is so void of
character and so void of Integrity his
words get that same level of
um weight in your life the same weight
as his actions do
which should be zero because he doesn't
tell the truth that's not who he is
it's not who he is
can he come around yeah
is he going to probably not
but if he's listening to this
bro you better be on the next plane out
or everything you're you are just talk
just talk talk talk talk talk talk
and you're burying your sweet wife
and this little boy
we'll be right back
[Music]
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling hallow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hallow.com deloney
all right we're back let's go out to
Dallas and talk to Marie dear Marie
what's up Dallas I'm sorry what's up
Marina you're good
from you for uh me and my mom excellent
what's going on
okay so it's codependency and freshman
so normally when you hear about these
you hear about it as like the kid living
in the Mama's basement
um this is actually kind of the opposite
so when I was in my mid-20s you started
asking for a little bit of money
um a couple years later she was down for
a year for medical stuff
um and during that year she ended up I
ended up paying half her bills and then
after that progressively it's just
gotten worse and the more that I enabled
her I thought you know oh this it'll
just help her get you know a break and
then she'll get back up she never got
back up and so exactly made everything
worse and worse and now we're at this
point where like she still has medical
stuff going on but she's also refusing
to stand up and try and live her life
anymore and so I made a conversation
where I can like I don't I don't want to
go for a throat and be like dude you
know this isn't okay because that never
helps anything but at the same time like
I need a way to tell her hey like I get
to have my own life you don't you you
can't just take over you know so one I
appreciate your heart man thanks for
loving your mom and I know it's gotten
sideways and out of control but
um that's a great impulse good for you
good for you thank you
um and also thank you for loving future
Marie enough to go whoa this is about
I'm about to dig a hole that I can't get
out of
um and you've done something that is
really rare
most of the time I have to start this
conversation by telling people to stop
blaming and that's not what you're doing
the way you framed this whole thing is I
kept doing and I kept doing and I kept
doing and I want to learn what I can do
next it's different
what an incred you're incredible that's
awesome oh thank you awesome
and any outcome is gonna suck just know
that going in
there is no magic conversation where
your mom's gonna go oh my gosh you're
right I'm so sorry and then she just
gets up and goes and gets a job
so yeah I want you to figure there was
no magic yeah put to bed that this ends
with you and your mom like like Waltzing
through a field of somewhere right and
there's just like snow coming down like
that's not gonna happen
um right
so what do you what's the what's the
best case scenario for you
um I would love for her to go get
counseling of her own I would love for
her to just pay like a portion or all of
her bills and to stop
giving me more and more because right
now what it feels like is she's slowly
handing me portions of her life and
making me responsible for them and then
she hates her life okay well I I can't
do anything for that like you're your
own person you have to take control of
your own life except you're taking
you're taking those things that she
hands you
right and and that's where we have the
issue because on one hand I'm like she's
having medical issues and stuff like
that so I feel like I can't responsibly
say I won't necessarily take it if you
if you actually have a problem but at
the same time like I don't want to take
things that
you don't actually need me to be taking
you know right
um I think you're gonna have to change
your language a little bit because her
definition of what she needs and your
definition of what she needs are going
to be different
so I think you getting out of her head
you getting out of what you think she
needs at a time
is is going to be important and you are
going to have to focus on here's what I
can provide
and here's what I'm willing to provide
and
some of those the the can and will those
are messy
those are messy because you can have
money in the bank and your mom's like
but you can just do it and you're saying
yeah but I'm not going to
because I've decided that I'm gonna use
that money in a different way and that
is a hard hard conversation so
does she have the ability to pay her
bills or she choosing not to go to work
does she have money in account somewhere
how what's this Gap
um she doesn't have a whole lot of money
in the account
um
she just quit her job
um she was a truck driver we were both
truck drivers um she went down
um for a medical reason and then she was
this is the second time in two years
she's gone down for medical so she
didn't want to come back to truck
driving so now she's job hunting
so is she living with you
yes part of it is
well when you say medical issues
um
give me a little more context
originally several years ago she went
down for a blood clot in her leg and
that's when this whole process actually
started and got really you know I
started paying more of her bills two
years ago she actually started um
I she was in Fort Worth Texas she had
been doing a run she was making 400 a
week I was making around 600 a week
um and she started having issues with
her bills and when I told her I'll give
you a little bit more but no more than
this amount
um she's but a month later she was in
the hospital for audible hallucinations
and then they got her sorted within a
week when she went to the hospital and
then two years later you know she had
gotten cleared to come back out well
around him two months ago she went off
the truck again because she was she was
saying she was feeling weird and she was
having a hard time focusing and and all
this and so then she went back into the
hospital and now she's leveling back out
again so but it's interesting timing
because it's like whenever I hold that
boundary I'm on I'm on Dave Ramsey's
baby steps too and so I told her I'm not
going to be helping with you know some
of the money stuff and so it's like
almost as soon as I set a boundary
there's
something here and I can't say it's not
something serious because she does go
into the hospital but at the same time
the timing is really interesting sure
um I yeah hospitalization doesn't isn't
a benchmark for how serious or not
serious something is they'll if you show
up they'll take you and they'll put you
on an IV and they'll put you on meds is
she getting is she getting
needed medication when she's there and
it levels her out and she comes back out
and doesn't take her meds
yes she took the original meds for a
little while and then she stopped taking
them
but she was fine so she stopped taking
them after a couple weeks but then she
was fine for a year and a half until I
told her you know hey I'm doing this
thing and also in a year I want to get
off the truck and go like to school okay
and that's something so there's a couple
of ways you can do this one one is
easier than the other okay okay
um and I'm sure people will write in on
YouTube comments or on the podcast
comments with their thoughts of what you
should be doing you can read those at
your peril
um there may be some good stuff in there
sometimes there's some good stuff
sometimes there's just a bunch of
harrowing awful stuff
um
step number one is I want you to focus
on where you want to be in three to five
six years
and I want you to reverse engineer that
plan that just means I want you to start
five years from now how old are you now
32. okay so 37 year old Marie where is
she working where does she live how much
money does she make
okay and then I want you to back that up
with all the way to tomorrow what do you
need to do starting tomorrow to get
there so if you want to go to college
and become a nurse
you're that's gonna be a four-year
degree plus some training you would need
to go get registered for classes summer
session two right and so you're gonna
start doing things now they're going to
get you there whatever it happens to be
that you want to do so that's step one
step two is be realistic with where you
are right now what are your finances
what's your debt situation what is your
living situation and be very realistic
about what you can afford and what you
cannot afford
Okay the third thing is is then you
begin to sit down with Mom and say
here's what I will and cannot do
now a very difficult pickle you're in is
evicting your mom
if you say if you're going to continue
to live here you've got to pay rent
and you've got to pick up the light bill
that's fair
that means you can't just sit at home
and you're not getting back on the truck
that's fine that means you've got to go
get another job that's not going to be
fun and pleasant but you're
participating in this household
the obvious answer is or what are you
gonna evict your mom and put it on the
street probably not
right the other option is you move or
you say in six months I'm getting a new
apartment I'm going to go to this
particular school I'm getting out of the
truck and I'm going to this college I've
saved up enough money to to not take on
any student debt I'm gonna go do this
thing but you come up with a plan where
you vacate your home that where you live
now
then she she's got six months you feel
bad for you're gonna feel bad either way
okay
and you've heard me say this but at some
point you're gonna have to choose guilt
over resentment because if this
continues you're going to hate your mom
and we do not want to go there no
no so you'd much rather feel guilty that
your mom is mad at you
then
every time I go to my own home and my
mother is there
she is completely abandoned any sort of
life that she wants to live and it's
misery
and I hate it you don't want to go there
okay and so I mean there's not a lot of
good options you're gonna feel bad
you're gonna feel weird either way you
go
would this work better if I got like a
family counselor or something like that
to mediate
will she even go
um she's said she doesn't sound excited
about it but she's agreed to go if I
really wanted to here's the thing and
it's your money
and so usually it's in reverse a parent
will call and say hey I'm paying for my
kids college I'm really worried about
them they seem more anxious or they seem
more depressed what I'll tell them is
you tell them as a benefit of receiving
my money
you have to go see a counselor
it's your money
and so your mom can make a choice of
either she doesn't get your help or she
takes care of herself
and I think it's important to call out
this feels really weird mom because I
feel like I'm acting like your parent
and in some ways I am and I want to
switch the roles back
I need my mom
and I miss my mom
do you see the difference there
yeah it's kind of call it's it's not
kind of it's calling out the awkward I'm
a huge fan of calling out the awkward
whenever there's an awkward conversation
I had one with my son the other night
and I just said hey
this is gonna be weird and he's like
okay Dad here we go but I just like to
call it out that way
um not always the best strategy but it's
the one I usually use so I think it's
taking all those awkward weird things
and just putting them out this
conversation is going to be hard this
conversation is going to be weird I am
running into a math problem I can't
support us both and eventually get me
out of the truck so that I can be
healthy and financially secure over the
Long Haul no pun intended like I it's
not working so I have to make some
different choices and I know that now my
choices are going to affect you so that
means you are going to have to make some
different choices whether you want to or
not
here's our option here's your options
and that's where you already having your
plan I am going to go to nursing school
I am going to go to Roofing school I
don't know what you want to do HVAC or
whatever whatever you want to do I am
going to go do these things
and so I'm not asking mom for your
permission or what do you think or I'm
not asking that I'm telling you what I'm
gonna go do and here's how that is going
to affect you and here's the choices you
have you can continue to pay rent and
that's going to allow you to stay here
um you can go see a counselor with me
because that's a part of me allowing you
to stay here or I'm moving in six months
to a one bedroom apartment in North
Carolina because that's where I'm going
to school whatever whatever it is you
want to do
um but again the template as you asked
for is you find you figure out what your
path is
number two you figure out the
mathematical realities of where you live
what it costs to be you and what it's
going to take to get you to this
to this destination
and then three be very dog I mean very
clear not dogmatic but be very clear
with your mom here's the challenges
here's the awkwardness here's the
challenges here's your two paths or
three paths that you get to choose
in any sort of well I'm just not oh you
don't love your mom expect that to
happen that's gonna be how she rolls
because that's how she's rolled for the
last several years
and I'm gonna be compassionate and
treated with respect and dignity
she doesn't want to be where she is
either
she doesn't want to be feeling more and
more depressed and more and more
helpless and more and more like she
can't take care of herself and her own
kid has to take care of her
which then feeds the shame cycle which
then feeds the cycle of I'm not doing
anything and this whole thing just gets
worse and worse and worse
so it just takes the adult in the
relationship which is you right now to
say I'm I'm hitting the stop button on
this we're controlled deleting this
thing
so hopefully that helps let me know how
those conversations go and if she wants
to call in I'd love to talk to her too
or if y'all both want to call in uh that
might be an interesting show and um
however I can help you as you head off
into this new Direction I just want to
tell you again how proud of you I am
you're going into this with the right
heart and the right spirit that you are
the only person you can change you can't
change them up can't change mom's
thoughts you can't change her actions
you can just change yours and yours will
affect yours but you are looking in the
mirror first I love it we'll be right
back
hey John deloney here I say it all the
time you can't wish your way to a better
life it boils down to being intentional
about what you do every day intentional
acts become healthy habits and one of
the most important things you can do to
improve your mental and physical health
right now starting tonight is to get
enough quality sleep and I know this
from personal experience and for me
great sleep starts with an incredible
mattress and that's why I love dream
Cloud mattresses whether you're a back
sleeper a stomach sleeper or a side
sleeper because your dumb dog is always
in the way dream Cloud's combo of gel
memory foam and coil technology keeps
you cool and comfortable all night long
and right now dream cloud is running
their biggest offer ever 40 off all
mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings exclusively for my
listeners visit dreamcloudsleep.com and
enter your promo code John deloney
that's dreamcloudsleep.com and promo
code John deloney
all right we are back let's go out to
Akron Ohio and talk to Andrew what's up
Andrew
hey John how you doing partying man
that's not true that's not true I'm at
work what are you doing
oh I'm finishing up some notes for my
work excellent but uh I I appreciate you
taking my call man I really appreciate
your wisdom and your honesty and I've
really enjoyed your show so thanks for
having me on you got it what's happening
well how can I help
so um find myself in a pretty
complicated situation
um in my marriage
been married almost four years now
um
and my wife has
um struggled with a lot of addiction and
there has been a pretty significant
amount of
um manipulation and deception that's
taken place over the last uh really the
entire course of our marriage what's her
uh what's her addiction of choice
yeah it's uh so she struggles with an
eating disorder so you know I guess
maybe not your traditional like drug or
alcohol addiction
um but to the point where uh you know
she's she's chosen to
um
manipulate
um myself and just situations and
deceives needs in order for it to to
manifest into
um take on you know binge Purge
behaviors and restrictive behaviors and
things so
she's been in and out of inpatient
Outpatient Therapy we've done counseling
marriage counseling and unfortunately
it's just the patterns have continued to
take place
so my question to you is
um
you know about three or four months ago
just after kind of realizing things were
still as as bad as they always have been
um
I started really struggling myself with
just panic attacks and
some pretty severe depression anxiety
just feeling so trapped by the situation
to the point where you know it made some
boundaries that were crossed and I had
her move back in with her parents
and so we're at a point now where what
were those boundaries were those
boundaries
um so unfortunately one of the only
objective measures for for growth and
for
um
for both of us to you know really have a
full picture of where she's at is weight
and just kind of measures of honesty of
checking in each day making sure that
everything she's saying and doing is
consistent with you know what we're
seeing as far as like
um
her weight
and um just was continuing to lose
weight and kind of stay like underweight
and um
so despite you know telling me
everything was going fine and she was
doing all the right things
was still just kind of seeing that
objective measurement
um
hopefully that makes sense yeah
yeah so
so you kicked her out unfortunately she
went to live with her parents
yep she's with her parents now so if
she's been there for the last
two months and there's just
you know she's very frustrated and angry
with me because
she wants me to move toward her and and
build back Trust
but at this point I mean trust is not
only damaged it's gone you know it's out
the window and um so I'm just struggling
to survive myself at this point you know
I'm I'm actually an ER Doc and I'm
struggling even at work sometimes to
stay focused just because the
it's just a constant thing on my mind
you know and um so I'm trying to figure
out how can I
guard my own hearts and my own mental
health
um
you know while the trauma is still kind
of continuing to happen even though
she's
telling me that it's not or she's
telling me that she's different even
though I'm still seeing objective
behaviors taking place that make me
pretty uh assured that they are still
happening so you're a medical doctor
I am yeah okay I can I can have a little
bit different conversation with you than
I I might with just like a
a a dad is a roof a husband is a roofer
or something sure
for some reason you have you are
taking her actions
let me say it this way
this isn't you're holding her
accountable for the results of an
illness
and you're making them very behavioral
in a way and then you're taking
you're taking her behavior personally
and so the best way I could I could
suggest this is uh that maybe analogy
and this may not work perfectly but
um
I have a seven-year-old little girl and
she has
um I she's had some respiratory
challenges some restricted breathing
recently and for a couple of nights in a
row
she came into a me and my wife's room at
3am
sick exhausted coughing from her what
felt like from her guts and
um unable to breathe and we're having to
run through breathing treatments and
stuff which is not normal for her
right
but she continued to come
to the one safe place
and what I didn't do was get really
pissed at her
for coughing
because that's a function of
her challenges with her lungs
and so you've got a wife with a
significant mental health disorder
and this the seeds of this are planted
long before y'all got together
right and you have two people who are
all about control
and you're exerting it in different ways
you have a very intellectual control
which is a very emotional control
and she's going to pull you using that
and you're going to try to pull her back
using intellect and so you get in this
strange dance
but you're getting really pissed that
she's coughing
the challenge with and you know this
from your training the challenge with
distorted eating
is using relationship as a as a weapon
just throws gasoline on that fire
yeah exactly you know what I mean
like for punishment for not for her
punishment for coughing was she doesn't
get to see you anymore or live in her
own home that was her punishment
there was a line that her coughing
crossed and you said you're out of my
life until you fix coughing
when they're really the only way to fix
coughing is relational connection and
then the healing can actually start
so I guess more so
as I told her over the years you know I
said I'm I'm not I'll never be upset
with you for struggling with mental
illness I said the only thing I I ever
want from you is your honesty yeah but
that is that's a function of it
sure
and I guess what I struggle is is not
having the foundation of of trust
and our marriage leaks over into to
every aspect of of the marriage because
for me it's like how can I trust you
with with anything when when I can't
trust you with just like these these
daily questions and and things you know
and
I just I worry you know like about a
future like when we have
kids or or like really difficult life
challenges you know not being able to
to trust her I just yeah so let's flip
us around
sure
I'm trying I really want to talk nerd
with you like it makes my heart feel
good that I'm talking like I get to talk
to a uh I mean you're way smarter than
me I can talk to a nerd I'm a nerd too
man well but I want to make sure people
can follow us
um
uh
uh let me say it like this it sounds
like you are treating her as a patient
and the difference is you get to weigh
her in and check her blood and her blood
pressure
every minute of every day
and so my question for you is what if
you stopped putting her in a position
when you know that shame
is one of the core DNA functions of
disordered eating
sure not putting her in a position to
have to lie it's the same thing I tell
parents if you know your kid took the
cookie you know it you see chocolate on
their face
start there don't say did you take that
cookie and then they're like no Mom and
then get pissed at him for lying you
just set up you just set that whole
thing up
just sit down and go hey you have
chocolate on your face you took my
cookies I told you not to and we're
gonna have to I'm gonna have to hold you
accountable for this action don't add
something to it so is there a way that
she becomes your wife and not your
patient
because you're creating a world that
somebody with her particular mental
health disorder and if you've listened
to this show you know it's rare that I
say that you I'm almost always saying
it's a context not an excuse right just
because you have anxiety and you may
even be you may have a you know a GED
diagnostic whatever you still got to
tell the truth right
this one this is the core function of
this is hiding in shame it's part of the
loop man and so what if instead of
saying did you eat today did you purge
today did you do this today
you just held her hand
and said I'm so happy to see you
how can I love you today
if you tried that for 30 days I might be
out to lunch man but I almost am willing
to bet that her her
parasympathetic system could finally
kick in she could breathe
yeah
but I do got to tell you I mean you know
we've been almost four years now we've
been married and I knew about this you
know pretty soon after we got married
because she was just obviously losing
weight didn't have a period for a year
and a half I mean got to the point where
she was down to 80 pounds and was being
it was dangerous and absolutely
dangerous absolutely
and threw off that whole time you know I
had a lot of people in my life saying
like hey man this is this is bad like I
think you should get out
and you know I defended her tooth and
nail and just said this is my wife this
is our lot and that was you know I mean
I'm not just trying to blow smoke
here you know I mean that was my
Approach was no matter what like there's
going to be Grace there's going to be
love like I'm going to encourage her
and I think but are you but are you
showing Grace and love the way that you
know how or the way she needs it
well I guess that's a good question I
mean the whole the whole weighing thing
didn't happen until
she came back from treatment because
that's kind of how they were and again I
know I'm not I'm not in that role of a
counselor or you know a dietitian but
like that's kind of how they were
continuing to monitor her her progress
and I I just I didn't know what to do I
mean I saw her continue to lose weight
I'm with you I I I'm terrified for you
you know this as well as I do for people
listening
um this is last I looked it was the
number one it's the most lethal mental
health disorder there is yeah yeah
um this is a scary scary thing and to
see someone you love wither away to 80 I
mean that's that is
that's all that's that's terrifying so
yeah I I I want you to hear me in no
shape form of fashion is this your fault
am I blaming you
mm-hmm Maybe here's an analogy that will
work my dad was a homicide detective
he's a trained
um question asker he also was the uh
hostage negotiator for the SWAT team so
if somebody had a bomb or somebody was
going to jump off a building they called
my dad in and he's got a very disarming
funny I learned every I mean I learned
the way I approached life from from him
okay
and they told him during training
you cannot bring this skill set to your
home because you'll melt your kids
and one of the most raw honest
conversations we ever had was several
years ago when he looked at me and said
I don't think I did a good job
and I remember
being a kid feeling like I was getting
interrogated
for did I finish raking the yard it was
an intensity to it and a directionist to
it you see what I'm saying it was the
professional skill set that he had
and he's just trying to get to the
bottom of it
he said man I I don't think I did a good
job of of not bringing that home
thank you kids we're the brunt of that
so what I'm suggesting to you is I don't
think she needs another physician at her
house she needs someone that just loves
and let me tell you this if you are done
in this marriage have the courage to be
done in this marriage
because you can get dangerously close to
wanting to be done with this and then
looking for every possible way to make
this the ending of this her fault
yeah if you leave that's a choice you
make have the courage to stand up and
make that choice
yeah are you done
uh getting pretty close I think to be
honest kind of feeling feeling pretty um
just bent like I have nothing left do
you have somebody else
no no okay
yeah
um but I appreciate that and makes a lot
of sense John so
um what's what's your next what's your
next move
she's still down to 80 pounds
no she's she's not she's
she's closer to a healthy weight at this
point I mean has not has not progressed
um over the past year what would she
need to do
for you to
actually let me let me give you this
analogy and if you've ever listened to
show you've heard me say this and I'm
just gonna say it again for everybody
yeah
the marriage you thought you would have
four or five years in
is not what has happened right
the woman you married in many ways is
different than the person you thought
you married and probably vice versa
yeah
the goal now isn't to try to get back
the goal now isn't to try to remember
when
we were dating and I was in med school
and we were all kind of crazy and I was
working these crazy hours and you'd
those days are over
the question you have to ask yourself is
are you willing
to work with her and is she willing to
work with you to rebuild something
completely new from this point forward
because that's really your only option
It's that or we both walk away
right
yeah yeah I certainly realize it's not
about trying to get back to what we
thought was because I mean in reality
that that never was you know yes and so
how long does she struggle with this
well I think I think a lot longer than I
realized
um and it got really severe after we got
married
um but I think she had some Tendencies
of disordered eating even back in high
school
she had a good relationship with her dad
um I do it does she
oh does she she does she does yeah
um it's he's always kind of
then uh
yeah I mean they've always been really
close I don't think he really opens up a
whole lot with her but do you supportive
with her dad no with her
I'm sorry do I have a good relationship
with her do you open up to her
oh yeah okay
yeah
I mean at this point uh you know the
last few times we've talked I've just
been a blubbering mess so there's not a
whole lot hidden at this point good
I mean I hate to tell you this but
that's that's the only the only the only
way this thing survives is if you are
all in
yeah and all in not trying to be the
reserved ER physician that says
you have some insert big fancy name but
it's the one that sits done holds a
patient's hand and said I'm so sorry
that's the guy she needs
the husband that says
not the not the clinician that is like
well you're up 2.3 body weight and
you're
she needs the guy that says I miss my
wife
and that's not even going to guarantee
it because she may not quote unquote
miss her husband
yeah
I think the question moving forward is
what is it going to take what what what
standards if you will and standards is a
bad word is a bad way to say that but
what would she have to do
what needs do you need Matt
how can she love you
and vice versa how can you love her
so maybe that's the the path if there is
one forward if there's some sort of
trial move back in for 30 days
a every single day how can I love you
today
I'm not going to ask you any questions
I'm not going to put you on any any I'm
not going to judge anything I'm not
gonna I'm not going to investigate you
I'm not going to run blood panels on you
you're not my patient you're my wife
how could I love you today
and you get to say what you need to be
loved
you get to say that out loud too
and y'all get to work together
and man I'm sorry that the woman you
love is sick sick sick sick
that breaks my heart she's in scaryville
but if she's stable over a year maybe
maybe we're on the on the right path
because I've seen that healing too
[Music]
thank you for loving her remember
the woman I love not my patient
she's the woman I committed everything
to
she's not a client
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we are back for like the
fourth go round of this uh trying to end
the show I'm not supposed to do that but
it's cool we've had like four takes
because we had one
Move Along
Kelly's not good at counting listen
today's song of the day
is by uh schizophrenic band who could
not figure out the size and scope of
their City
Little Big Town
ha I've named a lot of bands in my life
I just can't imagine being like we're
gonna go with big city I want to go with
little town
I don't know how you land here what is a
little big town by the way Kelly
I have no idea I
I don't well you're the musician no
do you know what I would just say a
little big town is like a big city like
Nashville but it feels like a small town
because everybody knows each other
bam or maybe we're putting too much
thought into it and they just came up
with a name the song's called better man
if they stole this from the mighty Pearl
Jams
the song goes like this actually hold on
we have to give credit where credit is
due this was written by Taylor Swift
just dropping that knowledge I feel like
just drop in that knowledge
oh boy
Taylor Swift writing a song for little
big sideways miniature gigantic town
city
song's called better man not Pearl Jams
but T Swifts Little Big Towns
and it goes like this
I know it just starts the music right
away let's end this show I know I'm
probably better off on my own than
loving a man who didn't know what he had
when he had it and I see the permanent
damage you did to me never again I just
wish I could forget when it was magic
I wish it wasn't 4 a.m standing in the
mirror saying to myself you know you had
to do it I know the bravest thing I ever
did was run
and that's what I think Kelly's gonna do
at the end of this show I love you guys
stay in school don't do drugs bye
foreign